великий колектив науково-педагогічних і
наукових працівників докторантів
аспірантів студентів і відповідні
наукові підрозділи кількість
науково-педагогічних працівників
впродовж останніх років Нам вдалося
зберегти натомість кількість наукових
працівників після суттєвого зменшення у
2014 році дається поступово збільшувати
і підготовка таких фахівців займає
як правило від сти до 10 років Доробок у
вигляді наукових публікацій здається
також зберегти на постійному рівні до
позитивної тенденції можна віднести
збільшення кількості монографій зокрема
у провідних закордонних виданнях
15% і попри сумарне зменшення кількості
патентів збільшилася частка патентів на
винаходи е є титульні сторінки наших
монографій і е розподіл публікацій за
науковими
напрямами Я порівняв з аналогічними
показниками для провідних університетів
Східної Європи саме будапестський
університет лоронда етвеша Карлів
університет місто Праги ілонський
університет місто Краків і хочу
відзначити три основні спостереження
по-перше в усіх університетах домінують
статті в галузі фізики та астрономії в
нашому університеті такий продукт
видають науковці фізичного хімічного
факультету факультету електроніки друге
у закордонних університетах на провідні
позиції виходить біохімія А нам в цьому
напрямі ще треба інтенсифікувати роботу
і третє у закордонних університетах
розподіл статей за напрямами є го
гомогеннішим я ще прошу звернути увагу
на ту сегмент зеленого кольору АКС інші
в нас він є найменшим тому наша мета як
класичного університету розширювати саме
ось е напрями наукових
досліджень
е нашими пріоритетними партнерами це за
публікаціями з які ми маємо це є в
рейтинговіх ттях це і нан і МОН України
за кордоном найтіснішу співпрацю має з
вчаними Польщі але також Чехії Австрії і
Німеччини стосовно наших періодичних
видань то зараз 37 найменувань входять
до переліку фахових видань
е Міністерства освіти і науки України
шість до міжнародних наукометричних баз
даних в звітному році працівники
університету захистили 137 кандидатських
і 14 докторських ертацій і
спостерігається позитивна динаміка для
ності захищений до докторських
дисертацій за останні три роки 5
1014 університет запровадив програму
підтримки працівників у здобутті
наукового ступеня доктора Наф Двері
університету відчинені для колег
партнерів перспективних наших замовників
для наших наймолодших наших потенційних
абітурієнтів і дякую міністерствої
освіти і науки за підтримку в тому числі
фінансову окремих ключових наукових закд
оце світлини з наукового піднику Нано
2016 який був проведений В день
незалежності 24 серпня інвестуємо також
в нашу
студентську молодь які в свою чергу
відповідають своїми
здобутками і збільшується кількість
учасників другого етапу Всеукраїнської
студентської олімпіади приємно
відзначити більшу кількість нагород
здобутими студентами як на олімпіаді так
і в конкурсі студентських наукових рубій
і тут ви бачите розподіл за двома
напрямами за природничоматематичним
напрямам І гуманітарним соціоекономічним
що здобутки мають студенти майже усіх
факультетів студенти знання уміння
використовують не лише теоретично але й
практично ось приклад один з найновіших
успішних стартапів
застукаю студенти магістри факультету
прикладної математики та інформатики
вигравали низку хакатонів і ось тепер
створили сервісну компанію е botsкw яка
працює на над провадженням штучного
інтелекту обсяг фінансування
науково-дослідних робіт з трьох джерел
показує позитивну динаміку ну хочу
звернути що наша мета - це щоби оцей
червоний і жовтий сегменти вирівнялися з
зеленим тобто щоб в нас було 50% ее е е
грантового фінансування і хочу також
звернути увагу на найнижчу колонку в
першому графіку яка включає гоздовірну
тематику в нас в минулому році було
шість гоздоговорів і
е тематика гоздорів'я актуальною
відображає нагальні проблеми регіону
вони стосуються енергетики і екології і
зокрема е е долучаємоться до вирішення
проблем е Львівського полігону твердих
побутових відходів це очищення
фільтратів і
інфільтратів стосовно спецфонд то він
має ще і інші надходження це і державне
замовлення дффд
грант президента відзначу новий проект
це друга позиція на слайді який є не
природничого напряму який спрямований на
вирішення важливої соціальної проблеми
міжнародна співпраця фінансується з
різних
джерел це
і це вже ми на грантах є Так ми дуже
цінуємо білатеральні програми
Міністерства освіти науки користємося
можливостями які пропонує дфдд і саме
стосовно гагрантів то гранти в основному
спрямовані на виконання досліджень в
галузі природничих наук і грантодавцями
виступають е різні як приватні так і
державні установи низки країн Швейцарія
Німеччина Канада е США е один з
міжнародних грантів має спеціальне
призначення це підтримка наукових шкіл і
е підтримка встановлення молодих вчених
16-му році було профінансовано
дослідження трьох наукових шкіл в тому
числі новоствореного інституту
молекулярної клітивної біології та
біотехнології а також п'ять проектів
молодих вчених і завдяки підтримці
Міністерства освіти і науки е в 16-му
році в університеті запрацював
національний контактний пункт
рамкової програми ЄС горизонт 2020 два
тематичні напрями майбутні нові
технології і обдаровані інноваційні та
безпечні суспільства і перший напрям
наразі не представленій в Україні
працюємо над інформуванням потенційних
аплікантів унівесиет дав
п'ять взяв участь в п'яти грантах за
програмою горизонт і чекаємо на
завершення всіх конкурсів вважаю за
необхідне щоби в класичному університеті
е представити різні тематичні напрями
наукових досліджень як фундаментальних
так і при ладних фінансованих
держбюджетом і до позитиву хочу віднести
відновлення наукових досліджень за
напрямом науки про життя оце фіолетовий
колір на правій
діаграмі е Тепер я перейду до основних
результатів за пріоритетними напрямами
ознайомлю вас з окремими науковими
результатами всього виконується 42
науково-дослідні роботи 10 тем за
завершилося у
2016 році от за напрямом проблеми
фізико-математичних і технічних наук 10
робіт і за спорідвненим напрямом
е проблеми сучасного матеріалознавства
ще три і тут я представлю ось тему
взаємодія інізуючого випромінювання з
нанокомпозитами ось фондаментальне
дослідження зцентиляційних
нанокомпозитів є важливими з огляду е на
розвиток сучасних детекторів різного
виду випромінювання це має подвійне е
призначення і ось цей Доробок виконавців
теми в 16-му році приведено також у
цифрах за наступним напрямом
е проблеми хімії розвитку хімічних
технологій п'ять науково-досвдних робіт
як приклад інтерметаліди використовують
якчаст як основу сучасних функціональних
матеріалів різного при значення це і
каталізатори акумулятори водньо хімічні
джерела енергії термоелектрики магніти і
зокрема надлегкі сплави літію магнію
алюмінію бору які були синтезовані в
вільському університеті характеризуються
високими
водоінсупційними характеристиками
наступна - Це розробка гібридних
наносистем Вона дозволила покращити
сенсорні властивості неорнічних
напівпровідників по відношенню до газів
мова йде про водяну пару і і аміак це
газоабсорбційні сенсори на основі
гібридних полімерних трубок і карбонових
нанотрубок і це важливим є для медицини
екології біотехнології видубної хімічної
промисловості за наступним
напрямом науки про життя розвиток
біотехнологій я представлю тему
функціонування е мікро
мікробоценозів техногенно змінених
територій і мета цієї роботи є
застосування мікроорганізмів для очистки
навколишнього середовища від сполук
важких металів інших полютантів і
створення мікробного паливного елемента
також проводяться дослідження в галузі е
проблем суспільних і гуманітарних наук і
тепер перейду до прикладних е робіт
перший напрям прикладних досліджень
стосується інформаційних та
комунікаційних технологій чотири
науковобласних робіт і в результаті
оцієї хвилини
Дякую цієї теми експериментальне
дослідження комп'ютерне
моделювання маємо
е комплекс новий комплекс для
вимірювання інтенсивності російного
світла тоді як наступна тема стосується
розробки біологічних сенсорів що
працюють в екстремальних умовах це різні
температури та радіаційні випоміння
представлений в наших дослідженнях і
напрям раціональ приро користування
зокрема в межах теми яка не екрані було
створено автоматизовану
картографо-інформаційну систему
ґрунтовно географічно рнування всієї
території
України науки про життя про Якій вже
згадува
це є тема розробка пристрою і
дослідження стосується експрес-методу
визначення гемоглобіну в крові а також
наступна - Це розробка це синтез нових
біологічноактивних речовин антибіотиків
розробка виконана на 100%. на переве
перевершує аналоги за сферою
застосування в п'ять разів і вже перші
штами актиноміценів було надійслено для
аналізу партнерам уберлін технічних
університет Я вже згадував про напрямок
дослідження в галузі психології ось це
наступна якраз тема вона стосується
діагностики дітей зі спектром
аутистичних порушень і напрям нові
речовини і матеріали я представлю
міжнародним гарантом ось це мета проекту
наповнення бази даних для міжнародної
бази для експрес ідентифікації хімічних
сполук наша співпраця з Міжнародним
центром триває вже понад 20 років і був
проведений семінар Минулого року який
відвідав президент компанії я ось всюди
з правого боку представляв вам прилади
Хочу зазначити що в університеті триває
е наш грант мільйон на новий прилад і ми
Стараємося принаймні кожного другого
року придбати унікальне обладнання з
позабюджетних коштів